enormous trucks battle away through
clouds of dust on a rutted and cratered
road the br163
for 40 years this highway that cuts a 1
000 mile gas through the amazon
rainforest has been used to transport
beef corn soya and logs to the outside
world on an industrial scale
in its wake the forest has been
destroyed
this is para state in brazil's amazon
the open fields tell a story of mass
exploitation of natural resources but it
always starts with the cutting of trees
and despite worldwide condemnation it
continues unabated
driving the br 163 it's easy to see the
burning that precedes the logging and
will soon follow it's illegal but they
don't bother to hide it anymore
lori is filled with precious valuable
wood everywhere
huge logs loaded on board and taken away
we pull off the road into a newly cut
section of the forest
it's a graveyard of thousand-year-old
trees
burnt to weaken them and then cut down
the loggers will return at night
these trees are worth a fortune their
size is staggering
but they're all dead now
legal or illegal logging it makes no
difference these trees will never be
replaced
the forest can't defend itself
there's much talk about the tipping
point where the rain forest simply can't
continue to exist i'd have to say in
this part of the amazon they've reached
that tipping point this is a new logging
area these are huge trees and look at
this one up here it's absolutely
enormous it's called
the samama
i mean it's at least 500 years old it
could be a lot more it's been pulled off
to the side it's super valuable
we don't know where it'll end up it's
very possibly though going to end up
in a
shop in europe or the united uk or the
united states
and we're not even hiding from the main
road here this is just
cutting down of trees in plain sight
most of what's transported on the br163
is at best murky but worst plane illegal
but the loggers the farmers and the
ranchers say it's transformed the
economy of paris state a transformation
more important than stopping climate
change
under brazil's president jeb bolsonaro
the cutting has increased
many here doubt his cop 26 commitments
will actually make much difference
trier nestles beneath the rainforest
it's the only town on the 163 that still
does
just 16 years ago though it was inside
the forest and all travelers passed
through it bringing trade
now it's off the main road the trees
have gone and nobody comes through
75 year old joao alves fedoza says the
road has been a disaster for their
economy and the environment
foreign
the traffic on the 163 never ever stops
occasionally it branches off to the
tributaries of the amazon
rivers that are the lifeblood of the
rainforest replaced now by tarmac and
mud
a unique vital part of the world's
environment
cleared out by humans
where even the living trees now stand
alone